Hey friends, Kaylin here from Teach Me How to Adult and we talk a lot on our show about how to live your best life while also balancing being a financially responsible human. So if you've been dreaming of that epic vacation or you want to explore a new city while still keeping your bills at bay, listen up because we've teamed up with Airbnb to share some ways on how you can easily become an Airbnb host. So when we took the big leap into adulthood and bought our first home, we purposely looked for a place that we could Airbnb whenever we're on vacation or just if we want to try working out of a different city because we both work from home and we love traveling.
大家好，我是《教我如何成年》的凯琳。我们在节目里经常探讨如何在过上精彩生活的同时，保持作为一个有财务责任感的人之间的平衡。所以，如果你一直在梦想那次史诗般的旅行，或者想探索一个新城市，同时又能控制好账单，请注意听，因为我们已经与Airbnb合作，分享一些如何轻松成为Airbnb房东的方法。因此，当我们迈出成年的大步购买第一套房子时，我们特意寻找了一个地方，以便在我们度假时，或者只是想尝试在不同的城市办公时，可以把房子通过Airbnb短租出去，因为我们俩都在家办公，而且我们非常喜欢旅行。
And it's honestly the perfect way to have the freedom and flexibility to travel or just go wherever you want while giving you that second stream of income and covering your cost while you're away. And you don't need a mansion or an entire floor of your home. It could honestly be as simple as just renting out a spare room or just occasionally doing it if you are traveling for a little bit. You could honestly be sitting on an Airbnb and not even know it. So whether you could use a little extra money to cover some bills or for something a little
说实话，这是获得旅行或去任何你想去的地方的自由与灵活性的绝佳方式，同时还能为你带来第二份收入来源，并在你不在的时候支付你的开销。你不需要一栋豪宅或家里的整整一层。老实说，这可以很简单，比如出租一间空房，或者在偶尔出行时顺便做一下。老实说，你可能正坐在一处潜在的Airbnb房源上却浑然不知。所以，无论你是需要一点额外的钱来支付一些账单，还是为了实现更有趣的愿望，
more fun, your home or spare room might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at Airbnb.ca forward slash host. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis center. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. At 11pm on Friday, March 14, 2003, a call was placed to the United Kingdom's emergency services telephone number 999.
你的家或空房间的价值可能比你想象的要高。访问 Airbnb.ca/host 了解具体价值。我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关机密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。2003年3月14日星期五晚上11点，有人拨打了英国的紧急服务电话999。
As per standard procedure, the operator answered by requesting which emergency service department the caller required, fire, police or ambulance, but they received no reply. The operator repeated the question multiple times, but the line remained silent. She then asked, if you are unable to speak but need an emergency service, tap the handset. There was no tapping, and after a minute of failed attempts to elicit a response from the caller, the operator transferred the call to silent solutions. This automated service was introduced by the London Metropolitan Police in 2002, after the widespread use of mobile phones led to an overwhelming amount of accidental calls
按照标准程序，接线员接听电话时询问来电者需要哪项紧急服务部门——火警、警察或救护车，但没有收到任何回复。接线员重复了多次问题，但电话那头依然沉默。接着她问：“如果您无法说话但需要紧急服务，请轻敲话筒。”没有任何敲击声，在试图引导来电者回应失败了一分钟后，接线员将电话转接至“静默解决方案”（Silent Solutions）。这个自动化服务由伦敦警察厅于2002年引入，当时移动电话的广泛使用导致了大量的误拨电话
being placed to 999. Silent solutions aimed to keep the emergency line free from congestion by filtering out the unintentional pocket dials from the legitimate crisis calls from those who needed help, but weren't in a position to speak out loud. When a call is transferred to silent solutions, an automated response instructs the caller to dial 55 if they require emergency assistance. If they comply, the call is then transferred to the relevant police response unit. If no action is taken by the caller, the line is terminated.
涌入999。静默解决方案旨在通过过滤掉无意的口袋误拨，将其与那些需要帮助却不便大声说话的真正危机求助区分开来，从而保持紧急热线的畅通。当电话转接至静默解决方案时，自动语音会指示来电者，如果需要紧急援助，请拨打55。如果照做，电话随后将被转接至相关的警察应急部门。如果来电者没有任何操作，线路将被切断。
As per protocol, the unresponsive phone call to 999 at 11pm on March 14 was transferred to silent solutions, and the system requested the caller to dial 55 if they needed help. Still, there was no response. An automated message advised, nothing has been heard from the caller, exchange please disconnect line. Almost two minutes after the call was initially placed, the phone line was disconnected. 17-year-old Hannah Foster was in good spirits on the evening of Friday, March 14, 2003, as she prepared for a night out with her best friend, Helen.
按照规程，3月14日晚上11点打进的那个无人应答的999电话被转接至静默解决方案，系统要求来电者如果需要帮助请拨打55。然而，依然没有回应。自动语音提示：“未听到来电者的任何声音，交换机请断开线路。”在最初拨打电话后将近两分钟，电话线路被切断。17岁的汉娜·福斯特（Hannah Foster）在2003年3月14日星期五的晚上心情很好，她正准备和最好的朋友海伦（Helen）一起外出过夜。
The teens had returned from an exciting day at college, where Hannah received the good news that she was on track to receive straight A's in her upcoming A levels. A fastidious and dedicated student, Hannah had recently been accepted to study medicine at two prestigious universities, and her top grades meant she was well on her way to fulfilling her lifelong dream of becoming a doctor. Going to head downtown that night to celebrate, Hannah and Helen met at the Foster's family home in Southampton, a port city in Hampshire on the south coast of England. Hannah lived on a tree-lined residential street with her mother Hillary, father Trevor, and
这两位少女刚从令人兴奋的大学生活返回，在学校里，汉娜收到了好消息：她在即将到来的A-Level考试中有望全部获得A。作为一个严谨且专注的学生，汉娜最近刚刚被两所声望卓著的大学录取学习医学，优异的成绩意味着她离实现成为一名医生的终身梦想又近了一步。那天晚上，汉娜和海伦前往市中心庆祝，她们在福斯特位于南安普顿的家族住所碰面。南安普顿是英格兰南海岸汉普郡的一个港口城市。汉娜和她的母亲希拉里（Hillary）、父亲特雷弗（Trevor）以及
14-year-old sister Sarah. The Foster's were a close-knit family and gave Hannah their full support. Beyond her academic pursuits, she had many other interests, including reading, drawing, and music, with a particular love for Californian rock band, the Red Hot Chili Peppers. Passionate about the environment and community, she helped out with a local Girl Guides organization in her spare time, relishing the opportunity to help teach the young members valuable new skills. She studied ballet as a child and was regarded as a graceful dancer, but was forced to give
14岁的妹妹萨拉（Sarah）居住在一条绿树成荫的住宅街上。福斯特一家是一个关系紧密的家庭，对汉娜给予了全力支持。除了学业追求，她还有许多其他兴趣，包括阅读、绘画和音乐，尤其喜爱加州摇滚乐队“红辣椒”（Red Hot Chili Peppers）。她热心环保和社区公益，在业余时间协助当地的“女童军”组织，非常珍视能有机会教导年轻成员掌握宝贵新技能的机会。她小时候学过芭蕾舞，曾被认为是一位优雅的舞者，但在青春期出现膝盖问题后，被迫放弃了
up this hobby after developing knee problems in her adolescence. During high school, she participated in the Duke of Edinburgh Awards, an international youth program that aims to help young people further develop their skills, fitness levels, and community involvement, achieving a bronze and silver award for her efforts. Without having a full schedule in the lead-up to her A-levels, Hannah didn't take life too seriously, always taking the time to socialize with her many friends. As she prepared for her night out on March 14, 2003, Hannah, who was 5'7", with short-cut brown hair and blue eyes, dressed in a light brown, long-sleeved polo jumper, a tweedy
这个爱好。高中期间，她参加了“爱丁堡公爵奖”（Duke of Edinburgh's Awards），这是一个旨在帮助年轻人进一步提升技能、体能水平和社区参与度的国际青年计划，并为其努力获得了铜奖和银奖。在A-Level考试前夕，没有被繁重日程压垮的汉娜并没有把生活看得太严肃，总是花时间与众多的朋友社交。在准备2003年3月14日的夜出时，身高5英尺7英寸（约1.7米）、留着短棕发和蓝色眼睛的汉娜，身穿一件浅棕色长袖Polo衫、一条粗花呢
brown skirt, knee-high boots, and an overcoat. She put the prepaid mobile phone her parents had previously given her as a reward for her good grades into her khaki-colored satchel. Prior to departing for their night out, Hannah and her best friend Helen put music on and danced around the Fosters kitchen, joined by Hannah's mother and sister. Hannah remarked that she couldn't wait until 14-year-old Sarah was old enough to join them on their nights out, telling her she would be a lot of fun to have around. Hannah and Helen left the house shortly after, with Hillary Foster waving her oldest daughter
棕色半身裙、及膝靴和一件外套。她把父母之前因为她成绩优异而奖励给她的预付费手机放进了她的卡其色斜挎包里。在出发外出之前，汉娜和她最好的朋友海伦放起音乐，在福斯特家的厨房里跳起舞来，汉娜的母亲和妹妹也加入了进来。汉娜感慨说，她等不及14岁的萨拉快点长大，好加入她们晚上的外出活动，并告诉萨拉有她一起玩一定会非常有趣。不久之后，汉娜和海伦离开了家，希拉里·福斯特在正门挥手送别她的大女儿，
off at the front door, making sure to leave a light on for when she returned home later in the night. Hannah and Helen made the one-mile journey to Southampton's inner-city area of Beavis Valley, a lively nightlife hotspot popular with students. Their first stop was to a pub called The Bent Brief, where Helen met her mother to collect some money for the night ahead. The pair then walked around to the corner to the Hobbit, a quaint fantasy-themed pub named after the Tolkien novel of the same name, where they each ordered a double vodka
还不忘留下一盏灯，等她深夜回家。汉娜和海伦步行了一英里，来到了南安普顿的比维斯谷（Beavis Valley）内城地区，这是一个深受学生欢迎的热闹夜生活聚集地。她们的第一站是一家名为“本特布里夫”（The Bent Brief）的酒吧，海伦在那里与母亲见面，拿了一些当晚要用的钱。随后，两人步行转过街角来到“霍比特人”（The Hobbit）酒吧，这是一间以托尔金同名小说命名的奇幻主题复古酒吧，她们各自点了一杯双份伏特加
lime and lemonade and watched the live band that was playing. The drink at the Hobbit would turn out to be their only alcoholic beverage for the night. By 10.30pm, they switched venues to a pub across the street called Soba, only to leave soon after. During their walk to their fourth destination, a bar called Lennons, the pair lost their motivation and decided to call it a night. Hannah escorted Helen to the bus stop on Portswood Road's commercial strip, where the pair waited for Helen's bus home.
青柠加柠檬水，并观看了一支现场乐队的表演。在“霍比特人”酒吧喝的酒成了她们当晚唯一的酒精饮料。到了晚上10点30分，她们换到了街对面的一家名为索巴（Soba）的酒吧，但没过多久就离开了。在步行前往第四个目的地——一家名为列侬（Lennons）的酒吧途中，两人失去了兴致，决定结束当晚的行程。汉娜陪着海伦来到朴茨茅斯路（Portswood Road）商业街的公交车站，两人在那里等海伦坐车回家。
The stop was only a five-minute walk from the foster home, and Hannah planned to walk the short trip alone after seeing off her friend. The bus arrived at 10.50pm, and Helen climbed aboard and took a seat. As the vehicle drove off, she made eye contact with Hannah, who was walking towards the Highfield Lane intersection, and the friends shared a final goodbye wave. At 5am the next morning, Hilary Foster arose to get ready for an early shift at Southampton General Hospital, where she worked as a cardiac nurse. As she made her way through the house, she noticed the door to Hannah's bedroom was
车站距离福斯特家只有五分钟的步行路程，送别朋友后，汉娜计划独自步行走完这短短的路程。公交车于晚上10点50分到达，海伦上车并找了个座位坐下。当车辆驶离时，她与正朝海菲尔德巷（Highfield Lane）十字路口走去的汉娜对视了一眼，朋友两人挥手作了最后的告别。第二天早上5点，希拉里·福斯特起床准备去南安普顿总医院（Southampton General Hospital）上早班，她在那里担任心脏科护士。当她穿过房子时，她注意到汉娜的卧室门
open, and the lights that had been left on in preparation for her return home were still on. This was odd, as Hannah always turned the lights off upon arriving home, and slept with her bedroom door closed. Upon realizing Hannah wasn't home, Hilary was hit with a wave of panic, as she hadn't received a text message or phone call to indicate she was spending the night at a friend's place. Hilary sent Hannah a text message asking where she was and whether she was okay, but by the
开着，而为了迎接她深夜回家而特意留的灯仍然亮着。这很不寻常，因为汉娜到家后总是会关掉灯，并且习惯关着卧室门睡觉。意识到汉娜不在家时，希拉里内心涌起一阵恐慌，因为她没有收到任何短信或电话说明汉娜要在朋友家过夜。希拉里给汉娜发了一条短信，询问她在哪里以及是否安全，但在
time she arrived for her shift at Southampton General, there had been no reply. By 6.30am she had tried calling Hannah on her mobile phone several times, but each of the calls rang out. Hannah's sister Sarah had gone away for the weekend, undertaking activities to complete her own Duke of Edinburgh Award, when she received a concerned phone call from her mother, asking if she knew Hannah's whereabouts. Sarah hadn't heard from her older sister either, and contacted Helen to check if the two friends were still together.
她到达南安普顿总医院上班时，依然没有收到回复。到早上6点30分，她曾多次尝试拨打汉娜的手机，但所有电话都无人接听。汉娜的妹妹萨拉这个周末外出了，正在进行完成她自己的“爱丁堡公爵奖”的活动，这时她接到了母亲焦急的电话，询问她是否知道汉娜的下落。萨拉也没有她姐姐的消息，于是联系了海伦，想确认这两个朋友是否还在一起。
Helen advised she hadn't seen or heard from Hannah since they parted ways that the ports would road a bus stop at 10.30 the night before. Hilary rushed home from work and began making phone calls to Hannah's friendship circle, but was unable to locate her. Her husband, Trevor, arrived home from work at 10.30am and immediately reported his daughters out of character disappearance to the police, who swiftly arrived to the Fosters home with sniffer dogs in tow. A thorough search of the residence was conducted, while Hannah's family and neighbours were
海伦告知，自从前一晚10点30分她们在朴茨茅斯路公交车站分道扬镳后，她就再也没有见过或听过汉娜的消息。希拉里匆忙赶回家中，开始给汉娜的朋友圈打电话，但未能找到她。她的丈夫特雷弗于上午10点30分下班回家，并立即向警方报告了女儿反常的失踪情况，警方迅速带着搜救犬赶到了福斯特家中。警方对住宅进行了彻底搜查，同时对汉娜的家人和邻居进行了
questioned, but there had been no sightings of the 17-year-old since her night out on the town. Hannah's mobile phone was still on, which was good news for police, as it meant the device was capable of emitting a signal to any telecommunications towers within its vicinity, enabling its location to be traced. After instructing the Fosters to stop calling the device to preserve its battery life, investigators used telecommunications data to trace the location of Hannah's phone whenever it received a text message or phone call.
询问，但自从这位17岁少女当晚外出后，就再也没有人见过她。汉娜的手机仍然开着，这对警方来说是个好消息，这意味着该设备能够向其附近的任何电信塔发射信号，从而能够追踪其位置。在指示福斯特一家停止拨打该设备以节省电量后，调查人员利用电信数据追踪了汉娜的手机在每次收到短信或电话时的位置。
Records showed that while Hilary Foster was attempting to contact Hannah earlier that morning, her phone emitted a moving signal travelling down the M275 motorway from South Ampton to the nearby city of Portsmouth, where it had since become stationary, indicating it was somewhere within the area. Phone records also revealed a 999 call had been made from Hannah's phone at 11pm the night before. Investigators obtained a recording of this call, which captured the emergency service operator making multiple unsuccessful attempts to elicit a response from the silent person
记录显示，当希拉里·福斯特当天早上早些时候试图联系汉娜时，她的手机发射出了一个移动信号，沿M275高速公路从南安普顿向附近的朴茨茅斯市移动，之后该信号便固定不动，表明它位于该地区的某个地方。通话记录还显示，前一晚11点曾用汉娜的手机拨打过一个999电话。调查人员获取了这通电话的录音，录音记录了紧急服务接线员多次试图让电话那头保持沉默的人作出回应，但均告失败。
on the other end of the line. The operator therefore transferred the call to the silent services division, but as the caller did not dial the necessary 5-5 to alert the service that they required assistance, the call was terminated. Audio technicians were able to enhance the 58 second long audio file of the call, revealing a muffled conversation occurring between two people in the background. A fearful female voice identified as Hannah Foster's was heard conversing with an older male with a South Asian accent who spoke in broken English.
因此，接线员将电话转接至静默服务部门，但由于来电者并未拨打必要的5-5来向服务部门发出需要协助的警报，电话最终被挂断。音频技术人员得以对这通长达58秒的通话音频文件进行降噪处理，从而显现出背景中两个人之间含糊不清的对话。一个被辨认为汉娜·福斯特的惊恐女声正在与一个带有南亚口音、说流利英语的老年男性对话。
Traffic and mechanical noises indicated they were travelling in a large vehicle, possibly a van. Some parts of the call were inaudible, but technicians were able to construct a partial transcript of the conversation, during which Hannah lied to the man, telling him she was 15 years old and her name was Sarah. She was then heard saying, that's my road, that's where I live. In response, the man ominously instructed her to, quote, hold your head down please. It was at this point that the call was transferred to silent services, with Hannah ignoring the
交通和机械噪音表明他们坐在一辆大型车辆中，可能是一辆面包车。通话的某些部分听不清楚，但技术人员得以拼凑出该对话的部分文字记录，期间汉娜对这名男子撒了谎，告诉他自己15岁，名叫萨拉。随后听到她说：“那是我的路，我就住在那里。”作为回应，该男子不祥地指示她：“请把头低下去。”正是在这个时候，电话被转接到了静默服务部门，而汉娜忽视了
system's request to dial 5-5. This failure to act, along with the fake identity she had given the man and their muffled, foreboding conversation, made it apparent to investigators that Hannah had made the 999 call inconspicuously, hoping to raise the alarm that she was in danger without alerting the man she was doing so. At approximately 2pm the following day of Sunday, March 16, 2003, a woman and her 14-year-old son were driving through West End, a village on the north-eastern outskirts of Southampton. As they travelled along Allington Lane, a rural road just off the M27 motorway, the
系统要求拨打5-5的请求。这种不作为，加上她给该男子提供的假身份以及他们含糊不清、充满不祥预兆的对话，让调查人员清楚地意识到，汉娜是在不引人注意的情况下拨打了999电话，希望在不惊动男子的同时发出自己处于危险之中的警报。2003年3月16日星期日（即次日）下午2点左右，一名女子和她14岁的儿子正驾车穿过西端（West End），这是一个位于南安普顿东北郊的小村庄。当他们行驶在离M27高速公路不远的乡村道路阿灵顿巷（Allington Lane）时，
teenager spotted something in a ditch 15 feet from the edge of the road. His mother pulled the car over to have a closer look, and tucked beneath the thick undergrowth and brambles that bordered one of the neighbouring pastures, the pair discovered the fully clothed body of a young female. Police were called to the scene, where they identified the deceased as Hannah Foster. A subsequent autopsy concluded that she had been beaten and sexually assaulted before being strangled to death, with toxicology tests revealing she had no traces of alcohol or other drugs in her system.
这名少年在离路边15英尺（约4.5米）的一个沟渠里发现了一些东西。他的母亲把车停在路边进行仔细查看，在夹在邻近牧场之间的一丛厚厚灌木和荆棘下方，两人发现了一具穿着完整衣物的年轻女性尸体。警方被召集到现场，经辨认死者正是汉娜·福斯特。随后的尸检得出结论，她生前曾遭到殴打和性侵，最后被勒死，毒理学检测显示其体内没有酒精或其他药物成分。
Although she was wearing shoes, her feet were caked in dirt and her clothing was in disarray, suggesting she had been stripped and then redressed by her killer. Scratch marks on her neck were believed to be defensive wounds sustained while attempting to loosen her attacker's grip. Investigators of Seaman found on Hannah's coat presented the most promising lead, however, when the sample was run through the police database, no match was found, as the perpetrator had no prior criminal record. Meanwhile, detectives broke the devastating news to the Foster family, who were overcome
尽管她穿着鞋子，但双脚沾满泥土，衣服也凌乱不堪，这表明她曾被凶手剥光衣服后又重新穿上。脖子上的抓痕被认为是她试图挣脱袭击者双手时留下的防御性伤痕。在汉娜外套上发现的精液给调查人员带来了最有希望的线索，然而，当该样本在警方数据库中进行比对时，并未找到匹配结果，因为作案者没有前科。与此同时，侦探们将这一毁灭性的消息告知了陷入悲痛之中的福斯特一家。
with grief. Hannah's parents, Hilary and Trevor, were required to formally identify their daughter, with Hilary later stating, I couldn't believe what I was seeing. There must be some mistake. The cold, bruised, embedded body certainly looked like Hannah, but where was the sparkle in her eyes, the radiant smile, the warmth and tenderness of her touch? Hannah was vibrant, graceful, gentle and so alive.
汉娜的父母希拉里和特雷弗被要求正式辨认他们的女儿，希拉里后来表示：“我不敢相信我所看到的。一定有什么搞错了。那具冰冷、瘀伤累累、陷入泥土的尸体看起来确实像汉娜，但她眼中的光芒、灿烂的微笑、她触摸时的温暖和柔情都去哪了？汉娜充满活力、优雅、温柔，曾经那么生机勃勃。”
I felt numb, paralyzed by grief and pain. Why Hannah? She had so much to live for, so much unfulfilled promise, so many talents, so much humanity and compassion to share. Police appealed for any witnesses who were in the Beavis Valley area late on Friday, March 14 to come forward, with a widespread media campaign ensuing. A police spokesperson warned. There have been no significant incidents reported in the area to date that can be directly linked
“我感到麻木，被悲伤和痛苦击得瘫痪。为什么是汉娜？她有那么多值得活下去的理由，有那么多尚未实现的承诺，有那么多才华，有那么多需要分享的人性和同情心。”警方呼吁在3月14日星期五深夜身处比维斯谷地区的任何目击者站出来，随后展开了一场广泛的媒体宣传活动。一名警方发言人警告说：“迄今为止，该地区尚未发生可直接与
to Hannah's disappearance, but we would advise the public to exercise caution. We would advise lone females walking in this area not to go out alone at night and to stick to brightly lit public roads until we have determined exactly what happened to Hannah. CCTV footage obtained from the area captured the two friends walking along the streets during their night out, but little else of interest. Speculation arose over the possibility Hannah may have been picked up by a taxi driver after waving Helen off at the bus stop, but this seemed unlikely, given the stop was a mere five minute walk from her home.
汉娜失踪挂钩的重大事件，但我们建议公众保持谨慎。我们建议独自在该地区行走的女性在夜间不要独自外出，并坚持走灯光明亮的公共道路，直到我们查明汉娜身上到底发生了什么。”从该地区获取的闭路电视监控录像捕捉到了两个朋友在夜出期间走过街道的画面，但没有其他太多有价值的信息。有猜测认为，汉娜在公交车站送别海伦后可能被某个出租车司机接走了，但这似乎不太可能，因为该车站距离她的家仅有五分钟的步行路程。
Regardless, police appealed for any taxi drivers who may have picked up a teenager matching Hannah's description to make contact. They obtained Hannah's home computer and began analysing her online history and mobile phone records to determine whether she may have arranged a secret rendezvous with someone after leaving her friend, but there was no evidence to support this theory. Just 24 hours after Hannah's body was found, an employee at a recycling plant in Portsmouth, the coastal city where her mobile phone last pinged off nearby telecommunications towers was looking inside a bottle recycling bin when he spotted a khaki coloured satchel with
无论如何，警方呼吁任何可能搭载过符合汉娜特征的少女的出租车司机与警方联系。他们获取了汉娜家中的电脑，开始分析她的上网记录和手机通话记录，以确定她在离开朋友后是否曾与某人安排过秘密约会，但没有证据支持这一理论。就在汉娜的尸体被发现24小时后，在其手机最后向附近电信塔发出信号的沿海城市朴茨茅斯的一家回收厂里，一名员工正在查看一个玻璃瓶回收箱，突然发现了一个卡其色的斜挎包，
a mobile phone inside. Both items were confirmed to belong to Hannah. This discovery added a third key location to the crime, in addition to Southampton where Hannah disappeared and the West End outskirts where her body was found. Two days after the discovery of her body, a candle lit vigil was held for Hannah at Southampton's Highfield Church, with hundreds of mourners gathering to pray, lay bouquets of flowers and sign a condolence book with loving messages and fond memories of the teen. The site where her body was found was marked with flowers and notes from grieving members
里面有一部手机。这两件物品经确认均属于汉娜。这一发现除了汉娜失踪的南安普顿以及发现她尸体的西端郊区之外，为这起犯罪案件增添了第三个关键地点。在她尸体被发现两天后，南安普顿的海菲尔德教堂（Highfield Church）为汉娜举行了一场烛光守夜活动，数百名哀悼者聚集在一起祈祷、敬献花束，并在吊唁簿上签名，写下充满爱意的讯息和对这位少女的美好回忆。发现她尸体的地点被社区中悲痛成员送来的鲜花和便条装点着，其中一张手写便条写道：
of the community with one hand written note reading. You are all in our thoughts at this very sad time. What a cruel world we live in. By the following day, Wednesday, March 19, investigators had received over 200 phone calls from the public. The case made national news headlines, with Southampton's shops, bus stops and street signs plastered with posters of Hannah and a description of the outfit she was last seen wearing, requesting witnesses to make contact with police.
“在这个非常悲伤的时刻，我们的思念与你们同在。我们生活在一个多么残酷的世界里。”到第二天（3月19日星期三），调查人员已接到公众打来的200多个电话。该案登上了全国新闻头条，南安普顿的商店、公交车站和路牌上贴满了汉娜的海报以及她最后一次露面时所穿衣物的描述，请求目击者与警方联系。
Hillary and Trevor Foster held their first public press conference to make an emotional plea for information regarding their daughter's murder, with Trevor saying, We as a family are devastated by the loss of Hannah. Hannah was a warm, kind-hearted girl who could always see the good in others. She was a gentle and graceful girl. What is important now is to catch the person responsible for this cruel and brutal act, so that no other family will have to suffer the trauma we are going through and the number of people coming empty-ness that has entered our lives, and destroyed our family.
希拉里和特雷弗·福斯特召开了他们的第一次公开记者会，含泪恳求提供有关女儿谋杀案的信息。特雷弗说：“作为一家人，汉娜的离去让我们痛不欲生。汉娜是一个温暖、善良的女孩，总是能看到别人好的一面。她是一个温柔优雅的女孩。现在最重要的是抓住这起残酷野蛮行径的罪魁祸首，这样其他家庭就不用再承受我们正在经历的创伤，以及那种侵入我们生活、摧毁我们家庭的空虚感。”
Investigators collected CCTV footage from the various locations Hannah's mobile phone was pinged on the night of March 14. As the audio recording of her 999 call had indicated she was being driven in a van, they were on the lookout for any matching vehicles travelling in those areas at the exact time Hannah's mobile phone was positioned to there. A total of seven different vans were sighted in the CCTV footage, prompting investigators to begin the task of identifying each of the vehicle's owners. Given the suspected killer had what sounded like a South Asian accent, they were confident
调查人员收集了3月14日晚汉娜手机发出信号的各个地点的闭路电视录像。由于她999通话的音频录音表明她当时坐在一辆面包车里，他们一直在寻找在汉娜手机定位到该地点的确切时间段内在这些区域行驶的任何符合特征的车辆。监控录像中一共发现了七辆不同的面包车，促使调查人员开始着手识别每辆车的车主。鉴于疑似凶手听起来有南亚口音，他们确信
the man they were looking for was not originally from the United Kingdom. On March 26, 10 days after Hannah's body had been found, BBC television show Crime Watch aired a segment about the case, reenacting the teenage's last known movements and appealing for assistance to identify her killer. Hillary and Trevor Foster made an appearance on the show to voice their torment, with Hillary explaining, quote, It's the not knowing what she's been through, and to just knowing how frightened she must have been at some stage, and we can't get beyond that.
他们寻找的男子并非土生土长的英国人。3月26日，即汉娜尸体被发现10天后，英国广播公司（BBC）的电视节目《罪案观察》（Crime Watch）播出了关于此案的一个片段，重现了这名少女最后已知的行踪，并呼吁协助辨认其凶手。希拉里和特雷弗·福斯特在该节目中亮相，倾诉了他们的痛苦。希拉里解释说：“引号，最折磨人的是不知道她经历过什么，只是知道她在某个阶段一定非常害怕，而我们无法摆脱这种阴影。”
After the episode of Crime Watch aired, close to 90 members of the public phoned the police, including Southampton resident James Dennis, who worked as a supervisor for ready-made meal producer Hazelwood Foods. James had noticed that one of his employees, 35-year-old delivery driver, Maninda Powell Singh Coley, had been acting suspiciously around the time of Hannah's murder. Furthermore, on the night of March 14, Coley had been in possession of one of Hazelwood Foods' distribution vans, and his delivery route passed through the key locations of the crime.
《罪案观察》这期节目播出后，将近90名公众打电话给警方，其中包括南安普顿居民詹姆斯·邓尼斯（James Dennis），他在成品菜生产商黑泽尔伍德食品公司（Hazelwood Foods）担任主管。詹姆斯注意到，他的一名员工、35岁的送货司机曼因达·鲍威尔·辛格·科利（Maninda Powell Singh Coley）在汉娜遇害期间表现得有些可疑。此外，在3月14日晚，科利拥有一辆黑泽尔伍德食品公司的配送面包车，而他的送货路线恰好经过这起案件的关键地点。
Police noted the registration number of Coley's van was already on their list of seven vehicles of interest, having been captured on traffic cameras travelling from Southampton along both the M27 and M275 motorways. At the exact time Hannah's phone was tracked moving on the same course. In the early hours of March 15, a petrol station security camera captured Coley's van travelling three times in different directions around the area where Hannah's body was eventually found. At 3.15 that same morning, he entered the petrol station and initiated his scheduled deliveries
警方注意到，科利的面包车的车牌号已经在他们那份七辆受关注车辆的名单上了，它被交通摄像头拍到从南安普顿沿M27和M275高速公路行驶，时间正好与汉娜手机被追踪到沿相同路线移动的时间吻合。在3月15日凌晨，一个加油站的保安摄像头拍到科利的面包车在最终发现汉娜尸体的区域周围不同方向行驶了三次。当天清晨3点15分，他进入加油站，开始了他预定的送货任务，
before travelling to Portsmouth, where Hannah's phone and bag were later recovered. This sighting was particularly significant, as Portsmouth was not part of Coley's delivery route, and he therefore had no legitimate reason to be in the area. After completing just half of his deliveries, he returned to the Hazelwood Foods depot, telling his boss he had a sore back and needed to go home to rest. Within one hour of receiving James Dennis' phone call, police arrived to Hazelwood Foods to seize the delivery vehicle in question, a white van with a distinctive refrigeration unit on top and the word Rockfield written across the bonnet.
然后前往朴茨茅斯，汉娜的手机和包后来就是在那里的回收箱里被找回的。这一目击情况尤为重要，因为朴茨茅斯并不在科利的送货路线上，因此他没有合法的理由出现在该地区。在完成了总共一半的送货任务后，他返回了黑泽尔伍德食品公司的仓库，告诉老板他背疼，需要回家休息。在接到詹姆斯·邓尼斯电话的一个小时内，警察赶到黑泽尔伍德食品公司，扣押了涉案的送货车辆——一辆白色面包车，车顶带有独特的冷藏装置，发动机罩上写着“罗克菲尔德”（Rockfield）字样。
Forensic analysts found traces of semen on the seats and a chrome pole covered in blood spatter and several strands of hair. As forensic testing of this evidence commenced, detectives made their way to Coley's home on Broadlands Road in Southampton, which was less than one mile away from the Fosters residence. Upon their arrival, they discovered there were no curtains in the windows or furniture inside, indicating the house had been completely abandoned. A check of Coley's background revealed he had relocated from India to the United Kingdom in 1993 as part of an arranged marriage to a UK-based Indian woman named Shalinda.
法医分析人员在座椅上发现了精液痕迹，在一根沾满血迹和数股头发的镀铬杆上也发现了痕迹。正当这些证据的法医检测展开时，侦探们前往位于南安普顿布罗德兰兹路（Broadlands Road）的科利家，该处距离福斯特住所不到一英里。到达后，他们发现窗户上没有窗帘，里面也没有家具，表明这所房子已被彻底遗弃。对科利背景的调查显示，他于1993年作为与一名在英国的印度女子沙林达（Shalinda）安排婚姻的一部分，从印度搬到了英国。
The couple had two sons, a six-year-old and a four-year-old. It didn't appear to be a happy marriage, with neighbors overhearing the couple fired often, describing Coley as a drunk and self-confessed gambling addict. Police were able to locate Coley's wife Shalinda and their two children, who were staying at her parents' house nearby. She explained her husband had travelled back to India to look after his mother, who was in a coma after being hit by a bus. While she refused to believe her husband could be responsible for such a heinous crime, Shalinda
这对夫妇育有两个儿子，分别六岁和四岁。这似乎并不是一段幸福的婚姻，邻居们经常听到两人争吵，并形容科利是个酒鬼兼自称的赌徒。警方找到了科利的妻子沙林达和他们的两个孩子，当时他们正住在她父母位于附近的家中。她解释说，她的丈夫已经回印度照顾因被公交车撞倒而陷入昏迷的母亲。尽管她拒绝相信她的丈夫会做出如此令人发指的罪行，但沙林达
allowed police to extract DNA samples from one of her sons to test against the forensic evidence uncovered from the delivery van. Police examined CCTV footage from London's Heathrow Airport and spotted Coley in transit on March 18, two days after Hannah's murder. Dressed in a lightweight suit and carrying only a small backpack, Coley was filmed as he checked into a direct flight to India's capital territory, Delhi. With a population of over 18 million people, Delhi is the fifth most densely populated city in the world.
还是允许警方从她的一个儿子那里提取DNA样本，以便与从送货面包车中发现的法医证据进行比对。警方检查了伦敦希思罗机场的闭路电视录像，发现了科利在3月18日（汉娜遇害两天后）过境的画面。科利穿着一套轻便西装，只背着一个小背包，被拍到办理直飞印度首都直辖区德里的航班登机手续。德里人口超过1800万，是世界上人口密度第五高的城市。
In a country that boasts an overall population of 1.2 billion, finding Coley was compared to looking for a needle in a haystack. As India shares borders with Nepal, China, Bhutan, Myanmar, Pakistan and Bangladesh, investigators also couldn't rule out the possibility that Coley had already fled to one of these neighbouring countries. Despite the challenges, British police and Hannah's family refused to give up on the search for her killer, with Hillary Foster later explaining, As parents, we had this absolute drive that nobody could ever get away with doing this
在一个总人口高达12亿的国家里，找到科利无异于大海捞针。由于印度与尼泊尔、中国、不丹、缅甸、巴基斯坦和孟加ylabel拉国接壤，调查人员也不能排除科利已经逃往这些邻国之一的可能性。尽管面临重重挑战，英国警方和汉娜的家人拒绝放弃寻找她的凶手，希拉里·福斯特后来解释说：“作为父母，我们有一种绝对的驱动力，绝不能让任何人对我们的女儿做出这种事却逃脱法网。”
to our daughter. From England, Shalinda contacted her husband's family in Chandigarh, a city in the Punjab region, approximately 150 miles north of Delhi. Coley's family confirmed he had recently been staying in town, although admitted his arrival was completely unexpected, as his mother had already been in a coma for three months and he hadn't mentioned any previous plans of visiting her. There was a collective sense of denial running through the family, with Coley's police officer brother Ishpreet refusing to consider he was a murderer.
在英国，沙林达联系了她丈夫位于昌迪加尔（Chandigarh）的家人。昌迪加尔是旁遮普地区的一个城市，位于德里以北约150英里处。科利家人证实他最近确实在镇上呆过，但承认他的到来完全出乎意料，因为他的母亲已经昏迷了三个月，而且他此前并未提及任何探望她的计划。家族中弥漫着一种集体否认的情绪，科利的警察哥哥伊什普里特（Ishpreet）拒绝相信他是凶手。
The morning after Shalinda's phone call, Friday, March 28, Coley shaved his head and thick beard and fled his hometown, allegedly leaving his family with no indication of where he was going next. The abject denial of Coley's possible guilt was also voiced by his wife in England. Shalinda told police that someone was attempting to frame her husband, revealing that on the day after Hannah's disappearance, he returned home noticeably upset with a visible scratch on his face. When she asked him what was wrong, he explained that the night before he had been drinking
在沙林达打完电话的次日，即3月28日星期五，科利剃光了头发和浓密的胡须，逃离了他的家乡，据称离开时没有向家人透露他接下来要去哪里。科利可能无罪的极端否认也由他在英国的妻子表达了出来。沙林达告诉警方，有人试图陷害她的丈夫，并透露在汉娜失踪的第二天，他回家时明显心烦意乱，脸上有明显的抓痕。当她问他怎么了时，他解释说前一天晚上他在一家酒吧喝酒，当他回到面包车时，有人进入了车内，把一具少女的尸体藏了进去。
at a pub and when he returned to his van, someone had gained access to the vehicle and stashed the body of a teenage girl inside. He panicked and drove straight home, unsure what to do. After telling Shalinda this story, Coley slept for a couple of hours before getting into the van and driving off. Bullwinder Chahal, the general secretary of Southampton's Gurdwara Sikh Temple, told police that two days prior to his overseas escape, Coley called him several times in tears requesting a meeting.
他感到惊慌失措，直接开车回了家，不知道该怎么办。对沙林达讲完这个故事后，科利睡了几个小时，然后上车开走了。南安普顿古德瓦拉锡克教寺庙（Gurdwara Sikh Temple）的总书记布尔温德·查哈尔（Bullwinder Chahal）告诉警方，在其海外逃亡的两天前，科利曾哭着给他打了好几个电话，要求见一面。
Bullwinder was reluctant as he had lent money to Coley in the past and was nervous he was going to ask for more, but he visited the distraught man regardless. As anticipated, Coley wanted to borrow money, this time to travel to India to see his sick mother before she passed away. He was acting erratically, all his belongings were piled into garbage bags and there was a distinct scratch under his eye. Bullwinder asked what was wrong and Coley explained his parents in law had arranged to have someone beat him up.
布尔温德很不情愿，因为他过去曾借过钱给科利，并且担心他是来借更多钱的，但他还是去见了这位心烦意乱的男子。正如预期的那样，科利想要借钱，这次是为了去印度看望病危的母亲，赶在她去世之前。他表现得很古怪，所有的物品都堆在垃圾袋里，他的眼睛下面有一个明显的抓痕。布尔温德问他怎么了，科利解释说他的岳父母安排人把他痛打了一顿。
Bullwinder refused to hand over the cash and to the next day he received a call from Coley telling him not to worry as he had borrowed the money from his father in law instead. He asked for a lift to the airport, but Bullwinder refused. As the evidence mounted against Coley, the results of forensic testing came back, revealing the semen found in his delivery van was a match to the DNA profile found on Hannah's code. The blood, spatter and hairs found in the van were also confirmed to have come from the teenager.
布尔温德拒绝交出现金，第二天他接到科利的电话，说不用担心，因为他已经从岳父母那里借到钱了。他请求搭车去机场，但布尔温德拒绝了。随着针对科利的证据越来越多，法医检测结果也出来了，显示在他的送货面包车中发现的精液与在汉娜外套上发现的DNA谱型相吻合。面包车中发现的血迹、飞溅血迹和头发也经证实来自这位少女。
Certain they had identified the man responsible for Hannah's murder. On Thursday, April 3, an international warrant was issued for Coley's arrest, charging the fugitive with murder, manslaughter, kidnapping, false imprisonment, rape and perverting the course of justice. In England, a person can be charged simultaneously with both murder and manslaughter, with a jury later deciding which of the two the defendant is guilty of. Whilst Britain had extradition agreements in place with India, bureaucratic red tape coupled with the fact that Coley was hiding in one of the most densely populated countries
确信已经锁定对汉娜谋杀案负责的男子后，4月3日星期四，国际刑警组织对科利发出了国际逮捕令，指控这名逃犯犯有谋杀、过失杀人、绑架、非法监禁、强奸和妨碍司法公正罪。在英国，一个人可以同时被控谋杀和过失杀人罪，陪审团随后将决定被告对其中的哪一项罪行有罪。虽然英国与印度签有引渡协议，但官僚主义的繁文缛节加上科利藏身于世界上人口最稠密的国家之一这一事实，
in the world meant carrying out the arrest would be no easy task. On the morning of Friday, April 11, a statement was released by the Foster family ahead of Hannah's funeral service which was scheduled to take place later that day. The statement read, Today, family and friends are joining together to give thanks for the life of Hannah. Nothing can bring our beautiful daughter back to us, and today will not be easy for any of us, but we will find strength in each other and strength in the continued support given to us by members of the community in Southampton and beyond.
意味着执行逮捕绝非易事。4月11日星期五上午，福斯特家族在汉娜定于当天晚些时候举行的葬礼之前发表了一份声明。声明写道：“今天，家人和朋友聚在一起，为汉娜的一生感恩。没有什么能把我们美丽的女儿带回给我们，今天对我们任何一个人来说都不容易，但我们将在彼此身上找到力量，在南安普顿及其他地区社区成员对我们持续的支持中找到力量。”
Feats inside Highfield Church were reserved for hundreds of Hannah's friends, relatives, schoolmates, teachers and the detectives working around the clock to solve her case, while the service was also broadcast via video link to an adjacent church centre for the many others who were unable to fit inside. Loudspeakers outside the building transmitted the service to the crowds of media and community members who had gathered to pay their respects. The service was overseen by Reverend Graham Archer who told the congregation, quote, Publicity surrounding Hannah's death has elevated her to almost celebrity status, but
海菲尔德教堂内部的座位留给了数百名汉娜的朋友、亲戚、同学、老师以及夜以继日侦破此案的侦探们，同时葬礼还通过视频连线播送到隔壁的教堂中心，供许多无法挤进教堂内部的人观看。建筑物外的扩音器将葬礼实况转播给聚集在现场表达敬意的众多媒体和社区成员。葬礼由格雷厄姆·阿奇尔（Graham Archer）牧师主持，他告诉会众：“引号，围绕汉娜之死的宣传把她提升到了几乎是名人般的地位，但
those of you who knew her as a friend or a family member should not let anyone rob you of your memories of how you remember her. Your memories cannot be taken away. They are part of her legacy to you. Today, the memories will have a painful edge, but they didn't when they happened, so don't be afraid to talk about her and those precious memories. A killer has already taken one life. In your handling of your responses, make sure he takes no more.
你们这些作为朋友或家人认识她的人，不应该让任何人剥夺你们对她的记忆，剥夺你们记忆中她原本的样子。你们的记忆是无法被夺走的。它们是她留给你们的遗产的一部分。今天，这些记忆会带有一丝痛苦的边缘，但事情发生时它们并非如此，所以不要害怕谈论她和那些珍贵的记忆。凶手已经夺走了一条生命。在你们应对这些反应时，确保他再也夺不走更多。”
Anna Zeco-friendly woven bamboo coffin was carried out of the church by members of her family, adorned with a wreath of pink flowers specially provided by a local florist where she had once conducted work experience. She was cremated in a private service, as students at her former high school gathered on faculty grounds to release 200 white balloons into the sky. On Wednesday, April 30, a trio of Hampshire investigators flew to India to liaise in person with Indian law enforcement, the British High Commission, and international police organisation Interpol.
安娜那环保的编织竹棺由她的家人们从教堂抬出，棺木上点缀着一圈粉红色的花环，这是她曾实习过的一家当地花店特意提供的。她在一次私人仪式上被火化，而她前高中的学生们则聚集在学校操场上，将200个白色气球放飞到天空中。4月30日星期三，三名汉普郡调查人员飞往印度，与印度执法部门、英国高级专员公署以及国际警察组织（国际刑警组织）进行面对面的联络。
Their efforts to locate Kohli were hindered when the Ministry of External Affairs refused to grant the British law enforcement team entry into the Punjab region, rendering them unable to speak to Kohli's family and gather information. Although Indian police understood the urgency of the investigation, they had their own overwhelming caseloads to take care of and were unable to prioritise the murder of a foreign national that occurred 4,000 miles away. This restrictive bureaucracy, coupled with the lack of resources available to the British investigators, cast serious doubts over whether their suspect would ever be found.
由于印度外交部拒绝向英国执法团队发放进入旁遮普地区的入境签证，导致他们无法与科利的家人交谈并收集信息，他们寻找科利的努力受到了阻碍。尽管印度警方理解调查的紧迫性，但他们也有自己海量的工作要处理，无法优先处理一个发生在4000英里外的外国公民谋杀案。这种限制性的官僚作风，加上英国调查人员可用资源的缺乏，给他们的嫌疑人是否能被找到打上了大大的问号。
By early May, with investigators in India struggling to make headway, Kohli's wife Shalinda released a public statement pleading for her husband to return to the United Kingdom and surrender to police for questioning. It read, For my sake and to the good of your children and your family, I urge you to hand yourself in to police and come back home so this can be sorted out. Wherever you are, please just go to the nearest police station and give yourself up. If you are innocent, this is the only way you can clear your name.
到5月初，随着印度的调查人员难以取得进展，科利的妻子沙林达发表了一份公开声明，恳求她的丈夫返回英国并向警方自首接受盘问。声明写道：“为了我，为了你的孩子和你的家庭的好处，我敦促你向警方自首并回家，这样事情就能得到解决。无论你在哪里，请直接去最近的警察局自首。如果你是无辜的，这是你洗清罪名的唯一方法。”
So please, just come home. Following this, the Hampshire detectives were finally granted permission to enter the Punjab region and headed straight to Kohli's hometown of Chandigarh to interview his family. They maintained they were not hiding him and insisted they had no idea where he had fled to, with his father, Jagadjeet, telling the press. I say if he is committed this crime, hang him. I will be the last person to protect him. If he is done this grave crime, he should be punished and he should face the music.
所以请回来吧。在此之后，汉普顿的侦探们终于获得了进入旁遮普地区的许可，并直奔科利的家乡昌迪加尔去盘问他的家人。他们坚称自己没有把他藏起来，并坚称他们不知道他逃到了哪里。他的父亲贾加德吉特对媒体说：“我说如果他犯了这个罪，就绞死他。我是最后一个保护他的人。如果他犯了这起重罪，他就应该受到惩罚，他应该承担后果。”
He should face the consequences, but I will not protect him. And if he is innocent, God will protect him. After two weeks in India, the Hampshire law enforcement team returned to the United Kingdom with greater support from both Chandigarh detectives and the Punjab authorities, who were now actively searching for the suspected killer. However, the case moved slowly, with Chandigarh police criticised for what the public perceived as a lack of action. Detective Inspector Dinka Gupta, who was initially leading the Indian inquiry, explained,
他应该承担后果，但我不会保护他。如果他是清白的，上帝会保佑他的。在印度呆了两周后，汉普顿执法团队带着昌迪加尔侦探和旁遮普当局的更大力支持回到了英国，他们现在正在积极搜寻这名嫌疑杀手。然而，案件进展缓慢，昌迪加尔警方因公众认为的不作为而受到批评。最初领导印度调查的副督察丁卡·古普塔解释说：
By the time all the paperwork was completed, the suspect had a big head start. He had a lot of time to plan his moves. I feel confident we should be able to find him, but it's difficult to say how soon. Hampshire detectives continued to travel to India over the following months, at one point teaming up with the premier investigating agency in the country, the Indian Central Bureau of Investigation. Rumours circulated that Kohli had been spotted across the border in the Nepalese city of Kathmandu, but there was no evidence to support this theory.
等所有的文书工作都完成时，嫌疑人已经占据了极大的先机。他有充足的时间来策划自己的行动。我有信心我们能找到他，但很难说会有多快。在接下来的几个月里，汉普顿的侦探们继续前往印度，一度与该国的主要调查机构——印度中央调查局合作。有传言称，科利曾越境出现在尼泊尔城市加德满都，但没有证据支持这一说法。
Months continued to pass by with no major progress in the investigation, and by early 2004, Hampshire police announced a reward of £70,000 for anyone with information that led to Kohli's arrest. This amounted to roughly 5 million rupees, a potentially life-changing payment, but insufficient attention from India's national media limited the population's awareness of the case, which prevented tips from coming in. In February, Britain's Home Secretary David Blunkett paid a visit to the Punjab Police Academy, where he appealed to the Punjabi people to assist police in capturing Kohli.
几个月过去了，调查仍无重大进展。到2004年初，汉普顿警方悬赏7万英镑，征集任何能促成逮捕科利的信息。这相当于大约500万卢比，是一笔可能改变人生的赏金，但印度国家媒体的关注度不足，限制了公众对该案的了解，导致线索无法汇集。2月，英国内政大臣大卫·布伦基特访问了旁遮普警察学院，他在那里呼吁旁遮普人民协助警方抓捕科利。
Quote, Not only in the interests of justice, but because he is wanted for questioning for the most heinous of crimes. The tragic murder of young Hannah Foster shows why it is so important we continue to forge even closer policing links. Only through continued and even closer cooperation and joint working can we catch those who believe they can flee UK justice by crossing an international border. The investigation languished for close to a year, with Kohli remaining a free man whose
他引用道：“这不仅是为了伸张正义，还因为他是最令人发指的罪行的通缉犯。年轻的汉娜·福斯特的悲惨谋杀案表明，我们继续建立更紧密的警务联系是多么重要。只有通过持续、更紧密的合作和共同努力，我们才能抓住那些认为可以通过跨越国际边界来逃避英国正义的人。”调查停滞了近一年，科利仍然是一个逍遥法外的嫌疑人，其
whereabouts were unknown. If Hannah had still been alive, she would have since celebrated her 18th birthday and completed her A-level exams, moving on to pursue medical studies at university. On Friday, March 12, 2004, two days prior to the one-year anniversary of her murder, Hillary and Trevor Foster released a statement via the media which read, This continues to be the worst time in our lives. We miss Hannah terribly. The injustice of her death is intensified by the knowledge that her killer is still
行踪不明。如果汉娜还活着，她本该庆祝18岁生日，完成A-Level考试，并继续在大学攻读医学专业。2004年3月12日星期五，在她遇害一周年纪念日前两天，希拉里和特雷弗·福斯特通过媒体发表了一份声明，其中写道：“这依然是我们一生中最糟糕的时刻。我们无比想念汉娜。一想到她的凶手依然
at large. We remain optimistic that the combined efforts of the Hampshire and Punjab police forces to secure an arrest will prove successful. On Sunday, March 14, to mark the one-year anniversary, a candlelit morning prayer service was held in honor of her and her family at Highfield Church. And Reverend Paul Harris told the 100 Strong Congregation to send a special prayer to the Foster family during what he called a time of continuing pain and suffering and desire for justice.
在逃，她死亡的不公就更加强烈。我们仍然乐观地认为，汉普顿和旁遮普警方为确保逮捕成功而共同做出的努力将会奏效。”3月14日星期日，为了纪念她遇害一周年，海菲尔德教堂举行了一场烛光晨祷仪式，以纪念她和她的家人。保罗·哈里斯牧师对在场的100多名会众说，在福斯特夫妇经历他所谓的持续痛苦、磨难以及对正义的渴望之际，向他们致以特别的祈祷。
Three months later, in June 2004, Hillary and Trevor Foster fronted a press conference announcing they would be traveling to India for the first time, in an effort to generate media attention and raise local awareness of the search for their daughter's killer. Regarding the purpose of their visit, Trevor explained, I think there was, at the start, an issue of vengeance, but I think now that feeling is reducing. If it wasn't, that would bring us down to the same level as him. What we want now is justice.
三个月后，即2004年6月，希拉里和特雷弗·福斯特出席了一场新闻发布会，宣布他们将首次前往印度，以争取媒体关注并提高当地对搜寻女儿凶手一事的意识。关于他们此行的目的，特雷弗解释说：“我想一开始确实有复仇的问题，但我想现在这种感觉正在减弱。如果不是这样，那就会把我们降到和他一样的水平。我们现在想要的是正义。”
That will mean a lot to us, and a lot to Hannah. We are increasingly frustrated that the prime suspect has not been located. We are, however, beginning to understand the difficulties of finding a fugitive who does not want to be found in a country as large and populous as India. The couple embarked on an 11-day visit to India on Saturday, July 10, joined by Detective Superintendent Alan Betts, who had been leading the British investigation into Hannah's murder. His employer, British multinational oil and gas company BG Group, funded a bilingual 24-hour phone line for witnesses to provide any information about Coley's whereabouts.
这对我们意义重大，对汉娜也意义重大。我们越来越沮丧的是，主要嫌疑人仍未被找到。然而，我们开始理解，在一个像印度这样幅员辽阔、人口众多的国家里，要找到一个不想被找到的逃犯有多么困难。”这对夫妇于7月10日星期六开始了为期11天的印度之行，同行的还有一直领导英国对汉娜谋杀案调查的侦探总督察艾伦·贝茨。他的雇主、英国跨国石油和天然气公司BG集团资助了一条双语24小时热线，供目击者提供有关科利下落的任何信息。
Posters were circulated around the Punjab region promoting the hotline phone number and the 5 million rupees award, along with images of Coley in different disguises. Hillary and Trevor spent the first few days of their trip attending various meetings with Indian politicians, Punjab police, and officials from the British High Commission. They held two press conferences where they shared Hannah's story, promoted the hotline number, and pleaded for anyone with information to come forward. Trevor said, This has been the first time we have felt strong enough.
旁遮普地区到处分发着海报，宣传热线电话号码和500万卢比的赏金，同时还附有科利穿着不同伪装的照片。希拉里和特雷弗在行程的前几天里，参加了与印度政客、旁遮普警方以及英国高级专员公署官员的各种会面。他们召开了两场新闻发布会，分享了汉娜的故事，宣传了热线电话号码，并恳求任何有线索的人站出来。特雷弗说：“这是我们第一次感到有足够的坚强。”
For us, the grieving process goes on and on, but we now feel we can cope with all this. Hillary added, We just want people to hear our story, see us and hear what we have to say. I hope and pray that they will use the hotline. The Fosters ordeal struck a chord with the Indian people, giving Hannah's murder investigation a desperately needed boost. In the first 24 hours of the hotline launch alone, 134 calls came through. And by July 15, police had amassed close to a dozen tips they believed could be valuable
对我们来说，悲伤的过程还在继续，但我们现在觉得我们能够应对这一切。希拉里补充道：“我们只想让人们听到我们的故事，看到我们，并听到我们要说的话。我希望并祈祷他们会使用这条热线。”福斯特一家的磨难触动了印度人民的心弦，给汉娜的谋杀案调查注入了急需的动力。仅在热线开通的前24小时内，就接到了134个电话。到7月15日，警方已经收集了近十几条他们认为对搜捕
in the hunt for Coley. One of the calls was placed by a taxi driver named Jason Lepcher, who lived in the city of Darjeeling, 1,700 kilometers northeast of Chandigarh. He had seen the news reports about Hannah's killer and noticed the suspect bore a resemblance to one of his customers, a man he knew only as Mike. Mike had told Jason he was a delivery driver on vacation from London and that his family remained in the United Kingdom. Each morning without fail, Mike purchased the daily newspapers as soon as they went on
科利有价值的线索。其中一个电话是一个名叫杰森·莱普彻的出租车司机打来的，他住在距离昌迪加尔东北1700公里的了大吉岭市。他看到了关于汉娜凶手的报道，并注意到嫌疑人的长相与他的一个客户很像，那个客户他只知道叫迈克。迈克曾告诉杰森，他是一名来自伦敦的度假送货司机，他的家人留在了英国。每天早晨雷打不动，迈克一开售就买日报，
sale and quickly scanned through the headlines before discarding the paper within minutes. In addition to Jason Lepcher's witness account, a Darjeeling hotel owner called the tipline to report a previous guest who looked like Coley but went by the name Mike Dennis. A barber and a news agent in Darjeeling also recognized Coley as one of their customers and a police officer from a neighboring state reported Coley bore a resemblance to one of his friend's new husbands. According to the officer, his 32-year-old friend Baharati Das was carrying out humanitarian work at a vaccination clinic in the town of Kalampong, 50 kilometers outside of Darjeeling.
迅速浏览头条新闻，然后在几分钟内把报纸扔掉。除了杰森·莱普彻的证词外，大吉岭的一位旅馆老板也打来热线电话，举报了一位长相酷似科利、但化名迈克·丹尼斯的前房客。大吉岭的一位理发师和报刊亭老板也认出科利是他们的顾客之一，来自邻省的一名警官报告说，科利长相酷似他朋友的新丈夫。据这位警官说，他32岁的女性朋友巴哈拉蒂·达斯正在大吉岭郊外50公里处卡兰蓬镇的一个疫苗接种诊所从事人道主义工作。
There, she met a doctor for the United Nations World Health Organization named Mike Dennis and the two were married just three months later. The officer handed investigators all the information he had on Dennis, including his mobile number and the residential addresses of his wife's family members. When local police descended on these addresses, they found no sign of Coley. At one property, a resident informed police that Mike Dennis had departed on a bus to Nepal with his wife the day prior. This was bad news for investigators, as the United Kingdom had no extradition treaty
在那里，她遇到了一个名叫迈克·丹尼斯的联合国世界卫生组织医生，三人仅在三个月后就结婚了。这名警官将他掌握的关于丹尼斯的所用信息交给了调查人员，包括他的手机号码以及他妻子家人的住宅地址。当当地警方突击搜查这些地址时，没有发现科利的踪迹。在其中一处房产，一名居民告诉警方，迈克·丹尼斯前一天已经和妻子坐上了去尼泊尔的巴士。这对调查人员来说是个坏消息，因为英国与尼泊尔没有引渡条约。
with Nepal. If Coley managed to cross the border from India into Nepal, there was every chance he would be out of their grasp for good. Police informed authorities near the border to be on the lookout for a man fitting Coley's description, who would likely be accompanied by a woman. Hillary and Trevor Foster were still in the midst of their media repealing India, when they received a word that Manindar Pal Singh Coley had been arrested after being cited by an off-duty police officer in the vicinity of the Nepalese border.
如果科利设法从印度越境逃往尼泊尔，他将很有可能彻底逃脱他们的掌控。警方通知靠近边境的当局密切注意一个符合科利特征、可能由一名女性陪同的男子。希拉里和特雷弗·福斯特当时仍在印度进行媒体呼吁，这时他们接到消息称，曼因达尔·帕尔·辛格·科利在尼泊尔边境附近被一名下班警察发现后被捕。
The couple appeared at a press conference immediately following news of the arrest, where the crowds of journalists cheered upon hearing confirmation that Coley was finally in custody after 16 months on the run. The Fosters thanked all those involved for their tireless work in bringing Hannah's killer to justice, with Trevor saying, Never in our wildest dreams did we expect an arrest to be made while we were in the middle of this short visit. We owe an enormous debt of gratitude to the Indian people.
在得知逮捕消息后，这对夫妇立即出现在一场新闻发布会上，在那里，大批记者在听到科利在潜逃16个月后终于被拘留的确认消息时欢呼雀跃。福斯特夫妇感谢所有为将汉娜的凶手绳之以法而付出不懈努力的人，特雷弗说：“我们做梦也没想到，在我们这次短暂访问期间竟然能逮捕嫌疑人。我们对印度人民感激不尽。”
Not only have they come forward to facilitate the arrest, but they have taken Hillary and die to their hearts in the short time we have been here. The full story of Coley's evasion was soon revealed. Upon fleeing England on March 18, 2003, he holed up in his hometown of Chandigarh, fleeing once he discovered the British police were onto him. He headed south to the city of Bangalore, where he operated under three aliases, Mike Dennis, Mike Davis, and Dennis Tracy. After seven months of maintaining a low profile, he moved to Darjeeling, where he claimed to
他们不仅站出来协助逮捕，而且在我们来到这里的短短时间里，把希拉里和黛（注：应为译文语误，指代希拉里）铭记在心。科利逃亡的全部故事很快水落石出。2003年3月18日从英格兰逃跑后，他藏匿在自己的家乡昌迪加尔，在发现英国警方盯上他后再次潜逃。他向南逃往班加罗尔市，在那里他化名三个假名：迈克·丹尼斯、迈克·戴维斯和丹尼斯·特雷西。在保持低调七个月后，他搬到了大吉岭，在那里他自称是
be a doctor for the World Health Organization, and earned a job at a Red Cross camp near Kalimpong, where he administered hepatitis vaccinations to children. It was here that he met Bahariti Das, the daughter of the camp's director, and the two soon began dating. Coley, who was living as Mike Dennis, made no mention of his wife and children back in the UK. After three months, the couple were married, celebrating the occasion with a modest reception at a hotel near Bahariti's family home.
世界卫生组织的医生，并在卡利姆蓬附近的一个红十字营地找到了一份工作，在那里他给孩子们接种乙肝疫苗。正是在这里，他遇到了营地主任的女儿巴哈蒂·达斯，两人很快开始约会。以迈克·丹尼斯身份生活的科利，对他在英国的妻子和孩子绝口不提。三个月后，两人结婚了，并在巴哈蒂家人住所附近的一家酒店举行了一场低调的招待会来庆祝这一时刻。
Photos taken at the event portrayed a happy and relaxed Coley as he danced in a circle surrounded by guests. Just three weeks later, he received an anonymous phone call, after which he was noticeably on edge. He told his new wife to pack her bag and to get ready to leave town, but refused to explain why. As the media coverage of Hillary and Trevor Foster's trip to India began to spread, Coley and Bahariti fled to the home of a relative in a village just half an hour from the border
活动中拍摄的照片描绘了一个快乐而放松的科利，他在被宾客环绕的圆圈中跳舞。仅仅三周后，他接到一个匿名电话，挂断后他明显显得有些紧张。他告诉新婚妻子收拾行李准备离开小镇，但拒绝解释原因。随着希拉里和特雷弗·福斯特印度之行的媒体报道开始传开，科利和巴哈蒂逃到距离尼泊尔边境仅半小时路程的一个村庄里的一处亲戚家中，不久后他们就在那里被捕。
of Nepal, where they were apprehended shortly after. The arrest came as a profound shock to Bahariti, who had no idea she was married to an international fugitive wanted for murder. In an interview following his arrest, she told journalists, I loved him so much. I know what the police are saying about him, but I still cannot believe it is true. What am I to do? I have been married, but now I have no husband.
这次逮捕对巴哈蒂来说是一个沉重的打击，她做梦也没想到自己竟然嫁给了一个因谋杀而被通缉的国际逃犯。在被捕后的一次采访中，她对记者说：“我太爱他了。我知道警察对他的指控，但我仍然无法相信这是真的。我该怎么办？我已经结过婚了，但现在我没有丈夫了。”
In our society, no one will ever want to marry me now. I'm finished. I am old goods. It was suspected that Coley's brothers, Ishpreet and Amrit, had been in contact with him throughout his time on the run, harboring him during his time in Chandigarh and supplying him with money and a fake passport to facilitate his new life. Police also believed that Ishpreet, who was a constable in Chandigarh, sent Coley emails about the international efforts that were underway to find him, enabling him to get
在我们的社会里，现在再也没有人想娶我了。我完了。我是过时货了。据怀疑，科利的兄弟伊斯普里特和阿姆里特在他逃亡期间一直与他保持联系，在他在昌迪加尔期间为他提供庇护，并向他提供资金和假护照以协助他开启新生活。警方还认为，身为昌迪加尔警员的伊斯普里特曾向科利发送有关正在进行的搜捕他的国际行动的电子邮件，从而使他能够抢占
a head start and evade capture. One month after the arrest, Coley made an appearance on Indian television channel New Delhi TV, saying he wanted to unburden himself by revealing the truth about what happened to Hannah Foster. He appeared calm as he made a full confession, sparing no details as he described the night of March 14, 2003, which started with a heavy drinking session at a local pub. As he left the venue, Coley saw Hannah crossing the road alone, and he climbed into his van, conducted a U-turn, and grabbed her from behind, threatening her to stay quiet.
先机并逃避抓捕。逮捕一个月后，科利出现在印度新德里电视台（New Delhi TV）上，称他想通过透露汉娜·福斯特遇害真相来卸下心头的重担。他在全面供认时显得很平静，在描述2003年3月14日那个夜晚时没有遗漏任何细节。那个夜晚始于当地一家酒吧的一场痛饮。离开时，科利看到汉娜独自一人过马路，于是他爬上面包车，掉头从背后抓住她，威胁她保持安静。
He forced her into his company van, driving her to an isolated place and sexually assaulting her. Afterwards, she threatened to tell her parents and police about the attack, which provoked Coley to strangle her to death. I was out of my mind, it was only later that I realised I had destroyed my life. Coley claimed he never told his wife in England, Shalinda, about the attack, instead explaining he was home late that night because he had gotten into a fight at the pub. This contradicted Shalinda's previous statements to police, in which she claimed Coley had
他强行将她塞进公司的面包车，将她带到一个偏僻的地方并对她实施了性侵犯。事后，她威胁要将这次袭击告诉她的父母和警方，这激怒了科利，导致他将她勒死。我当时失去了理智，直到后来我才意识到自己已经毁了自己的人生。科利声称他从未将这次袭击告诉他在英国的妻子莎琳达，而是解释说他那天晚上回家晚是因为在酒吧里打了一架。这与莎琳达先前对警方的供述相矛盾，她曾声称科利曾
informed her there was a teenager's body in his van. Coley claimed he fled to India because he needed his brother's support and wanted to change his life. Tired of running and ready to face the consequences, Coley remarked, I am unburdening myself now because one day I have to face God. I want to open my heart. I feel light, unburdened. When asked if he wanted to say anything to Hannah's family, Coley remained silent.
通知她，他的面包车里有一具十几岁女孩的尸体。科利声称他逃往印度是因为他需要兄弟的支持，并想要改变生活。厌倦了逃亡并准备面对后果的科利评论道：“我现在卸下包袱，因为总有一天我要面对上帝。我想敞开心扉。我感到轻松，卸下了包袱。”当被问及是否有什么话想对汉娜的家人说时，科利保持沉默。
Up until this point, his wife in India, Baharati, had been convinced of his innocence, praying he would be released for the crime she believed he was wrongfully accused of committing. After seeing the televised confession, she told the Times of India newspaper she felt cheated, but also relieved that Coley had not harmed her during their short relationship. Quote, Now I have to learn to live with the fact that I lived with a criminal. Why did God have to make me live with a criminal? Days after the confession was aired, Coley retracted his statement, claiming the Punjab police had forced him to provide the false confession.
在此之前，他在印度的妻子巴哈拉蒂一直坚信他是清白的，祈祷他能被无罪释放，因为她相信他是被诬告犯下了罪行。在看到电视上的供述后，她告诉《印度时报》，她觉得自己被欺骗了，但同时也松了一口气，因为科利在他们短暂的恋爱关系中没有伤害她。她引用道：“现在我必须学会接受这样一个事实：我和一个罪犯生活在一起。上帝为什么要让我和一个罪犯生活在一起？”供述播出几天后，科利撤回了他的供述，声称旁遮普警方强迫他作出了虚假供述。
Due to the retraction, media outlets in Britain were prohibited from publishing anything about the confession, and the extradition process became even more challenging. Efforts to deport Coley to face trial in England began in October 2004. Seemingly determined to make the process as difficult as possible, he accused the Hampshire police of being racist and argued he wouldn't receive a fair trial in England due to prejudice against Asians. He claimed to be unwell and failed to show up for court appointments, leading to force the Germans.
由于翻供，英国的媒体被禁止发表任何关于这份供述的内容，引渡过程变得更具挑战性。将科利引渡回英格兰受审的努力始于2004年10月。他似乎决心让这个过程尽可能困难，他指责汉普顿警方种族主义，并辩称由于对亚洲人的偏见，他在英国不会得到公正的审判。他声称自己身体不适并缺席法庭约见，导致（警方）强制执行。
As he had done so from the beginning, Coley's brother Ishpreet publicly spoke out in support of his brother, telling the media he had been framed on account of his race. His first wife, Shalinda, travelled to India from the UK to attend the extradition hearing and testify on her husband's behalf, despite him having since married another woman. She claimed the statement she supplied to police during her husband's time on the run, in which he came home the day after Hannah's abduction, nervous with a scratch on his face and talking about the body of a teenage girl being in his van, was a complete fabrication coerced by Hampshire police.
正如他从一开始所做的那样，科利的弟弟伊斯普里特公开站出来支持他的哥哥，告诉媒体他是因种族原因而被诬陷的。他的第一任妻子莎琳达从英国赶到印度参加引渡听证会，并代表她的丈夫作证，尽管他后来已经娶了另一个女人。她声称，她丈夫在逃亡期间她向警方提供的供述——即她丈夫在汉娜被绑架的第二天回家，神情紧张，脸上有抓痕，并谈到他的面包车里有一具十几岁女孩的尸体——完全是受到汉普顿警方胁迫而捏造的。
She also filed an affidavit alleging British officials had held her hostage, refusing to let her travel to India until they came under international pressure to do so. Coley's second wife, Baharati, had another change of heart and once again became convinced of his innocence, speaking out in his defence. In a 2005 interview with Times of India, she said she hoped her husband would be cleared of the crimes and returned to live with her. The extradition process continued for several years, with Trevor and Hillary Foster returning to India on numerous occasions in an attempt to speed up the legal proceedings and ensure
她还提交了一份宣誓书，声称英国官员扣留了她，拒绝让她去印度，直到他们承受国际压力才放行。科利的第二任妻子巴哈拉蒂再次改变心意，重新坚信他是清白的，并为他辩护。在2005年接受《印度时报》采访时，她说她希望丈夫的罪名被洗清，并回到她身边生活。引渡过程持续了好几年，特雷弗和希拉里·福斯特多次重返印度，以试图加快法律诉讼程序并确保
the case remained in the news. They spoke publicly about how emotionally exhausting and frustrating it was that the process was taking so long, but acknowledged there was little that could be done in the Indian system to help bring them justice sooner. In February 2007, as the four-year anniversary of Hannah's murder approached, Hillary Foster told the Southern Daily Echo newspaper, After more than 100 court proceedings and 35 appeals, Delhi's High Court judge finally determined there was sufficient evidence for Coley to face trial in the UK for Hannah's
此案继续保持在新闻热度中。他们公开谈论这个过程历时如此之久是多么令人情绪精疲力竭和沮丧，但也承认印度的体制内无能为力来帮助他们更快地伸张正义。2007年2月，随着汉娜遇害四周年纪念日的临近，希拉里·福斯特对《南部每日回声报》说，经过100多场法庭审理和35次上诉，德里高等法院法官最终裁定有足够证据将科利引渡回英国，接受汉娜谋杀案的
murder. On Saturday, July 28, 2007, exactly three years after his arrest, Coley was extradited to England, where he was formally charged with the murder, manslaughter, rape and false imprisonment of Hannah Foster, as well as perverting the course of justice. He was the first person successfully extradited from India to the UK. Coley's trial began on Monday, October 13, 2008, at the Winchester Crown Court. The now 41-year-old had pled not guilty to all charges, with the redacted confession he made on Indian television deemed inadmissible in court.
审判。2007年7月28日星期六，也就是他被捕整整三年后，科利被引渡到英国，在那里他被正式指控犯有谋杀、过失杀人、强奸、非法监禁汉娜·福斯特以及妨碍司法公正罪。他是第一个从印度成功引渡到英国的人。科利的审判于2008年10月13日星期一在温彻斯特刑事法庭开始。现年41岁的他对所有指控均不认罪，他在印度电视上做出的已被删节的供述在法庭上被裁定为不可采纳。
The prosecution had to rely on the physical and circumstantial evidence available, including the DNA and CCTV footage, Hannah's mobile phone records and the recording of her 999 call. An enhanced version of the call was played to the jury, with Hillary and Trevor Foster telling the court the fear in their daughter's voice was palpable. Coley's defence team attempted to pin the crime on their client's former Hazelwood food supervisor, James Dennis, who had tipped police off about Coley in the early days of the investigation.
检方不得不依靠现有的物证和间接证据，包括DNA和闭路电视监控录像、汉娜的手机通话记录以及她拨打999报警电话的录音。法庭向陪审团播放了经过增强处理的通话录音，希拉里和特雷弗·福斯特告诉法庭，他们女儿声音中的恐惧显而易见。科利的辩护团队试图将罪责归咎于他们当事人的前黑尔伍德食品主管詹姆斯·*尼斯，后者在调查初期曾向警方举报了科利。
In the years before Hannah's murder, James had lent Coley £16,000 to help him sort his life out, but instead, Coley had gambled the money away. When James demanded he repay the money, Coley ordered the debt be cleared, threatening to go public with a fictitious rumour that he had an affair with James's wife. In response to this attempt at blackmailing, Coley claimed that James and his brother orchestrated an elaborate revenge plot against him, wherein he was abducted, bound and blindfolded and then forced to rape Hannah Foster, justifying why his semen had been found in his van and on her clothing.
在汉娜遇害前的几年里，詹姆斯曾借给科利1万6千英镑帮他整理生活，但科利却把钱赌光了。当詹姆斯要求他还钱时，科利命令免除这笔债务，并威胁要公开一个虚构的谣言，称他与詹姆斯的妻子有染。作为对这种勒索企图的回应，科利声称詹姆斯和他的兄弟针对他策划了一场精心策划的复仇计划，他在其中被绑架、捆绑并蒙上双眼，然后被迫强奸了汉娜·福斯特，以此来解释为什么在他的面包车里和她的衣服上发现了他的精液。
James Dennis took the stand to vehemently deny these allegations, with his wife also testifying she barely knew Coley and had never been romantically involved with him. Prosecution lawyer Nicholas Haggin accused Coley of being a self-confessed liar, saying he had five and a half years to concoct this wild and elaborate story. You have told the jury what you did to Hannah, but you substituted yourself instead of her. On Tuesday, November 25, 2008, after six weeks of trial and five hours of deliberations, the jury reached a verdict, finding Meninda Powell, sing Coley guilty of Hannah Foster's murder. He showed no emotion as the verdict was delivered, slightly shaking his head, while Hannah's
詹姆斯·丹尼斯走上证人席，激烈否认这些指控，他的妻子也作证说她几乎不认识科利，也从未与他有过浪漫的恋爱关系。控方律师尼古拉斯·哈金指责科利是一个自认的撒谎者，称他有五年半的时间来捏造这个荒谬而复杂的谎言。你已经告诉陪审团你对汉娜做了什么，但你用自己取代了她。2008年11月25日星期二，经过六周的审判和五个小时的审议，陪审团作出了裁决，裁定曼因达·保罗·辛格·科利谋杀汉娜·福斯特罪名成立。在宣读裁决时，他没有表现出任何情绪，只是微微摇了摇头，而汉娜的
family openly wept. Prior to sentencing, a victim impact statement prepared by Hilary Foster was read to the court by Hannah's aunt, moving several members of the jury to tears. Hilary spoke of the pain her family had endured upon not only losing Hannah under the most violent of circumstances, but from the prolonged suffering Coley had caused by purposefully evading police detection, fighting extradition proceedings, and arguing that his human rights be respected when he had so callously disregarded her daughter's right to life. She said had it not been for her other daughter Sarah, she would have lost the will to live.
家人则公开痛哭。在宣判前，汉娜的阿姨在法庭上宣读了希拉里·福斯特准备的受害者影响陈述，令陪审团的多名成员泪流满面。希拉里谈到了她们一家在不仅在最暴力的情况下失去汉娜时所承受的痛苦，而且还因为科利蓄意逃避警方搜捕、抗拒引渡程序、并在极其冷酷地漠视她女儿生存权利的同时还争辩说要尊重他的人权，从而造成了长时间的折磨。她说，如果不是因为她的另一个女儿莎拉，她就会失去活下去的意志。
Every statement read, When a mother gives birth, she has an immediate, instinctive need to nurture and protect her child. I would give anything to change places with Hannah, to take away the terror and pain she suffered that night. For the rest of my life, I will feel the guilt that I wasn't there when she needed me most. She died terrified and alone with an evil stranger. I feel as though Coley has ripped out my heart and stamped on it.
每一份宣读的声明都写道：“当一个母亲生下孩子时，她有一种直接的、本能的需求去养育和保护她的孩子。我愿意付出一切来和汉娜交换位置，带走她在那个夜晚遭受的恐怖和痛苦。在我的余生里，我都会感到内疚，因为在她最需要我的时候我不在场。她在一个邪恶的陌生人面前惊恐而孤独地死去。我觉得科利好像挖出了我的心并狠狠踩在上面。”
Hannah was a gentle, peace loving girl who was never able to cope with the raised voices and certainly not any threat of violence. She would have been frozen with fear, unable to run or fight. The proverbial lamb to the slaughter. We cherish every moment we spent with Hannah. We have so many happy memories. I can see her now running along the beach with Sarah, stopping to practice her ballet exercises.
汉娜是一个温柔、热爱和平的女孩，她从来无法应付高声喧哗，更不用说任何暴力威胁了。她当时一定吓得呆若木鸡，无法逃跑或反抗。正如人们常说的待宰羔羊。我们珍视与汉娜度过的每一刻。我们有那么多快乐的回忆。我现在还能看到她和莎拉一起在海滩上奔跑，停下来练习芭蕾舞动作。
So slight and graceful, hardly leaving a footprint in the sand. I miss her quiet ways, snuggled up with a book in the garden or cuddling up with her father on the setty to sneak some warmth. I miss those intimate chats. I miss her so much. The sense of loss is unbearable. We are heartbroken and will always remain so. Hannah, your short life enriched the lives of so many people.
她是如此苗条优雅，在沙滩上几乎没有留下脚印。我想念她安静的样子，在花园里蜷缩着看书，或者在沙发上和父亲依偎在一起取暖。我想念那些私密的聊天。我太想念她了。这种失落感是无法承受的。我们心碎了，也将永远如此。汉娜，你短暂的一生丰富了无数人的生活。
You'll never be forgotten. Loved forever. My darling little girl. May you now rest in peace. Presiding judge Justice Keith addressed Coley directly as he said, It took a long time for you to be brought to justice, but the law caught up with you in the end. The jury saw through your lies, and you stand there exposed as a heartless and contemptible
你永远不会被遗忘。永远爱你。我亲爱的小女孩。愿你现在安息吧。”主审法官基思法官直接向科利发表讲话，他说：“你被绳之以法花了很长时间，但法律最终还是追上了你。陪审团看穿了你的谎言，你站在那里，原形毕露，是一个冷酷无情、卑鄙无耻的男人，绑架并强奸了一个17岁、对生活充满无限希望的女孩，然后冷血且蓄意地剥夺了她的生命，这样她就无法用手指认你的罪行。”
man who abducted and raped a 17 year old girl with everything to live for, and then callously and quite premeditatedly took her life so she would not be able to point the finger of guilt at you. For Hannah's murder, Coley was sentenced to life in prison with a minimum term of 24 years to run concurrently with an additional 12 years for rape and six years for false imprisonment and kidnapping. Taking into account time served awaiting extradition to the UK. The sentence means Coley will be eligible for parole in 2030 at the age of 63.
因谋杀汉娜，科利被判处无期徒刑，最低服刑期为24年，与因强奸罪被判处的额外12年以及因非法监禁和绑架罪被判处的6年刑期同时执行。考虑到等待引渡回英国期间已经服刑的时间，这一判决意味着科利将在2030年以63岁的年龄获得假释资格。
Outside court, the Foster family voiced their disappointment in the sentence, saying they believed Coley should spend the rest of his life in prison. Trevor Foster said, This sentence gives him the right to a second chance at life, a second chance he never gave Hannah. To see Coley's life valued in this way when he showed such utter disregard for Hannah's is hurtful beyond measure. The punishment should fit the crime, in this case it certainly did not.
法院外，福斯特一家对这一判决表示失望，称他们认为科利应该在监狱里度过余生。特雷弗·福斯特说：“这个判决赋予了他重获新生的权利，而这是他从未给予汉娜的第二次机会。看到科利的生命以这种方式被评估，而他对汉娜的生命却表现出如此彻底的漠视，这是无比痛苦的。惩罚应该与罪行相符，但在这种情况下，绝对没有做到。”
The desperate and discreet 999 Corps placed by Hannah Foster on the night of her abduction was discussed during her murder trial with prosecution lawyer Nicholas Haggan telling the court. Hannah probably thought that the operator would listen to the conversation and work out that she was being held against her will and that the operator would contact the police. Unfortunately Hannah would not have known that there was a system in place to prevent accidentally dialed emergency calls from blocking up the system. This call was disconnected after only a very short time and so there was no response to
在谋杀案审判期间，讨论了汉娜·福斯特在被绑架当晚拨打的绝望而隐秘的999报警电话，控方律师尼古拉斯·哈甘对法庭说：“汉娜可能认为接线员会听这段对话，并弄清楚她是在违背意愿的情况下被扣押的，接线员会联系警察。不幸的是，汉娜不会知道当时有一个系统可以防止意外拨打的紧急电话堵塞系统。这通电话在很短的时间后就被切断了，因此她的求救没有得到任何回应。”
her attempt to get help. To avoid similar situations from happening again, the UK police watchdog launched a campaign to raise awareness of 999's silent solutions feature. An instruction guide released by the independent office for police conduct advised callers to tap buttons or cough into the phone if they find themselves unable to speak directly to the emergency services operator. The silent solutions feature that required callers to dial 5-5 to receive assistance was also heavily publicised, a requisite that may have impacted Hannah's fate had she been
为了避免类似情况再次发生，英国警方监督机构发起了一项运动，以提高人们对999“静音解决方案”功能的认识。独立警察行为办公室发布的一份操作指南建议报警人，如果发现自己无法直接与紧急服务接线员通话，可以在电话里轻拍按钮或咳嗽。“静音解决方案”功能要求拨打者拨打5-5来获得协助，这也得到了广泛宣传，如果汉娜当时知道这一点，这可能会影响她的命运。
aware. Following Coley's arrest, the reward money was distributed between a dozen Indian citizens who provided police with pivotal information that led to his capture. Taxi driver Jason Latcha was one recipient, receiving 5,000 pounds for alerting police to Coley's presence in Darjeeling. Jason had come from a poor family but had benefited from a quality education and had always been his dream to open a school that provided free education for underprivileged children.
在科利被捕后，悬赏金分发给了十多名向警方提供导致其落网的关键信息的印度公民。出租车司机杰森·拉查是获奖者之一，他因向警方通报科利在大吉岭的踪迹而获得了5000英镑。杰森来自一个贫困家庭，但受益于优质教育，他一直以来的梦想是开办一所为贫困儿童提供免费教育的学校。
Using his portion of the reward money, he purchased a plot of land in a small village in a remote, poor area in North East India, and in 2005 opened a free school named the Hannah Memorial Academy. Jason Stated More than the money, it is the feeling of having helped the police nab such a dangerous criminal that made me happy. A year later, Jason picked up two British tourists who were visiting Darjeeling and told them about the school. The couple, Christine Browning and Roger McLevity visited the facility and were inspired to
他用自己那部分的赏金在印度东北部一个偏远贫困地区的小村庄买了一块地，并于2005年开办了一所名为“汉娜纪念学院”的免费学校。杰森表示：“比起金钱，那种协助警方抓获如此危险罪犯的感觉才是我最高兴的。”一年后，杰森接载了两名到大吉岭旅游的英国游客，并向他们讲述了这所学校的事情。这对夫妇克里斯蒂娜·勃朗宁和罗杰·麦克莱维蒂参观了该设施，并深受启发而决定提供帮助。
help. Upon returning to the UK, they tracked down the Foster family to tell them about the great efforts Jason was making in honour of their daughter. They began collecting charitable donations and books to send to India, with the Hannah Memorial Academy soon growing to accommodate 125 students. A new road has since been constructed to gain better access to the school, with the mayor of Darjeeling naming it the Hannah Memorial Road. A local doctor visits the school regularly to provide free checkups and treatments to
回到英国后，他们找到了福斯特一家，告诉他们杰森为了纪念他们的女儿所做出的伟大努力。他们开始收集慈善捐款和书籍送到印度，汉娜纪念学院很快发展到能够容纳125名学生。此后，一条通往学校的新路已经修建，大吉岭市长将其命名为“汉娜纪念路”。当地的一名医生定期访问学校，为学生提供免费的体检和治疗，该学校现在还充当脊髓灰质炎疫苗接种中心，使其成为对汉娜的一个恰当的致敬，她曾梦想有一天成为一名医生。
the pupils, with the school now serving as a polio vaccination centre, making it a fitting tribute to Hannah, who dreamed of one day becoming a doctor. A statement from Hillary and Trevor Foster on the school's website reads, Losing Hannah in such circumstances has made us overly cynical and distrustful. Finding out that this school project is a genuine philanthropic gesture from Jason has gone a long way to restoring our faith in human nature. We thank him for naming the school after Hannah, which has made us both very grateful and very proud.
希拉里和特雷弗·福斯特在学校网站上发表的一份声明中写道：“在这样的情况下失去汉娜，让我们变得过于愤世嫉俗和不信任他人。发现这个学校项目是杰森发自内心的慈善举态，极大地恢复了我们对人性的信念。我们感谢他以汉娜的名字命名这所学校，这让我们感到非常感激和自豪。”
She had a huge appetite for learning, we're sure that will rub off on all those bright-eyed eager children who will benefit from this school. In Southampton at the rear of Highfield Church, an 18-inch bronze statue of a dancing girl titled The Spirit of Youth has been erected in Hannah's honour, accompanied by a plaque which reads, Hannah was a much admired and respected student, bright, friendly, intelligent and caring, not only towards her fellow students, but also her love and respect for the world we live in.
她对学习有着极大的热情，我们确信这会感染所有那些将受益于这所学校的、目光明亮渴望求知的孩子们。在南安普顿海菲尔德教堂的后方，树立了一座18英寸高、名为《青春之魂》的跳舞女孩青铜雕像，以纪念汉娜，旁边还配有一块牌匾，上面写着：“汉娜是一位备受钦佩和尊敬的学生，聪明、友好、富有同情心且关爱他人，不仅对同学如此，她对我们生活的世界也充满了爱与尊重。”
As a talented dancer herself, this figure brimming with energy and grace is designed to be an inspiration to other young people. It's the same church where years earlier Hannah was solemnly farewelled by her family, friends and the greater Southampton community. During the poignant service, her friend Haley had delivered a poem which read, Hannah, Hannah, softly dream of a golden sun in a valley of green. I feel your magic everywhere, in the breeze on my face and the sun in my hair. Dance through the mountains and skip down the stream.
作为一名才华横溢的舞者，这个充满活力和优雅的雕像旨在激励其他年轻人。就是在这座教堂里，多年前汉娜被她的家人、朋友和整个南安普顿社区庄严地送别。在那个凄美的仪式上，她的朋友海莉朗诵了一首诗，其中写道：“汉娜，汉娜，在绿色的山谷里柔和地梦想着金色的太阳。我到处都能感受到你的魔法，脸上的微风和发间的阳光。在群山中起舞，在小溪旁跳跃。
Hannah be free and a softly dream. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
汉娜，自由地去吧，做个轻柔的梦。”这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。